[Music]
we all remember og's incredible ti win
last year
[Applause]
from the anime grade betrayal that was
fly in s4's departure oh gee with the
fortitude to stick through it after
dealing with such a boy oh
the look there from no child from og's
insane run from a last place ranking to
the aegis
i would not have picked them as a
favorite for a single series they played
at t.i
and somehow they did it og's story was
the stuff dreams are made of
send another story
but the thing that made it all the more
incredible was their 20 year old rookie
mid laner
not only was he picked up just three
months before ti topius thompson of its
simon
had virtually zero land experience
before setting foot on the biggest stage
in dota
3 000 in your pocket you come to tr you
get an email from notel you're a ti
champion
what thanks to one tournament this quiet
and unassuming finn went from streaming
in his bedroom to shaking hands with the
president
a year ago right now if someone had told
you that you would be playing in the
grand final of ti-8 would you believe
them
no no from a pub star with a small hero
pool to the single most explosive rookie
in the history
of competitive gaming
thompson was pretty unknown before
joining og what little reputation he had
he built by climbing to the top of the
european leaderboards
all with very little professional
experience thompson
a pub star who has been playing for
years thompson
is unique in that he is extremely
entertaining and he has streamed his
entire
journey from being a pretty good pub
player to one of the best players in the
world
over the last few years the thing is for
the top ranked player in europe
thompson played some pretty weird [ __ ]
in addition to having a small hero pool
thompson did not play traditional
mid-laners instead he played heroes like
monkey king
and arc warden and uh
what's up boys what's up
his only saving grace was his formidable
invoker but even then
he saw fit to add his own unorthodox
twist
by building meteor hammer an item that
was so useless at launch the community
called it the meme hammer
where most evokers are relatively
worthless in the beginning of the game
his is diving your towers with a
quasweck spirit vessel
dropping meme hammers on your racks by
12 minutes
in fact thompson's weird heroes and
stupid builds ended up pissing off a lot
of people he played with
especially the pros puppy actually
lashed out at him in a pub game
the problem was that the bigger he got
the more skeptical everyone became
he is not the pub star everyone thinks
he is he's good but he's never going to
be a tier one in your face great player
like
if you watch tops he just doesn't have
the mechanical skills to do and he's a
very good player but
he's not going to be the next miracle
the next zuma well
almost everyone this guy has he might
not have experienced like competitively
but
when it comes to like playing dota the
guy
that is extremely experienced like he
has a perfect understanding
of what he does like all the heroes he
plays
how he wants to play them and stuff og
were once the best dota team in the
world
the esteemed og a multi-major winning
team
who won four out of the five valve
majors before the dpc
when it came to majors og were virtually
untouchable
the problem was that despite almost
always being the favorites
they suffered humiliating losses at ti
the philippines have eliminated oh gee
gnz have done it the dream the reality
wow look at them cheering the booth they
have to be so incredibly happy with that
win
and by mid 2018 even the team's results
outside of ti had begun to decline
eventually they lost fly and s4 to evil
geniuses
i can just say that the way it happened
was was not nice
towards the ones that were left behind
as we were left with obviously no
no options and as you said that we're
talking like a couple hours because we
before we have to fly to the super major
and obviously the international
seb gerax and no tail were in dire need
of a carry and a mid laner if they
wanted to have
any hope of qualifying for ti and so
they called thompson
for thompson it was pretty pretty quick
taga has just been playing pubs
and yeah he i don't think he hesitated
even for a second
from the outside looking in though hoji
had been gutted despite their best
efforts to put together a roster in time
for ti
it seemed all but certain they'd bomb
out of the qualifiers and that eg
had a real shot of lifting the aegis
with their former players
eg will take your young your europeans
to play for our screaming masses
and with the international 8 being in
vancouver arteezy's hometown
the team feels right at home but against
every odd
og did make it to ti they earned
europe's only qualifier spot and took
their place in the group stage og i
really wondered if they were gonna have
a good performance after
birmingham it's actually when i started
to wander good rock
perfect fatal bonds the mystic players
are bouncing and everywhere but it's the
it's the double concussive orbs as well
they're all the shots it's just an extra
all for everyone
and yeah this is the game gg gg is the
call
og will be the european representative
through the qualifiers going to the
international 2018.
and at t.i thompson set out to prove
that he wasn't just a pub star with
weird tastes then he was a mid laning
microwave
meme hammering specialist one that knew
the ins and outs of not only his own
heroes but his opponents too
it's kind of a big loss i kind of forgot
about his bottom line
oh my god he doesn't even get a chance
to fall on out double damage monkey king
drops on top of him kicks him out
thompson
look at the wrap around onto s4 again
though shroud is there
talking quick with the tornado emp combo
someone needs to come across and help s4
as s4 just getting solo killed here by
thompson
tornado thompson he's in the back of the
meter
coming down thompson with the saves
again
doing it big time on the main stage a
cold
calculating chat wheeling machine that
thompson he's actually got some
damage miss uphill is it going to happen
no it doesn't the crepify
he just has to wait and with the blast
hudson
he has been an absolute genius thompson
is actually sticking around has the
sentry advantage here
so does know what ami is up to kind of
looks like he's baiting at the
yeah you did do that he was beating it
he was beating it before long it became
clear that
thompson was exactly what og needed a
soldier
someone who would keep fighting no
matter how hopeless it seemed
it's like okay yeah they won that one
but what about the next one okay what
about the next one and they just refuse
never say die
someone who shared og's ability to make
bat [ __ ] comebacks against
insurmountable odds
thompson nice defend hector over very
visible you've got a very very low life
mirana
but og they can't find the target x
dover he's got the grip he's got the
control he's got the kill
thompson is down but he is up where the
echo
slams forward
there's the dumb there's the play girax
the savior of
og another tv coming forward hookshot
from fy gets involved in the fight the
thompson will arrive
hexing up onto fy the leap out the
fissure is available is there a
follow-up
dobson is there they push forward they
get the control and they're bringing fy
down
lgd with four heroes who do not have buy
back
oh gee they are gonna push the lead
comes forward
they've got the control x nova he'll go
down
this is the game lgt has nothing left oh
gee
have done it it goes the distance it
goes to three
the rest of course is history og ran
through the entire upper bracket before
mounting an incredible comeback against
psg lgd
in what's now considered the best ti
final of all time
leaving aside his mechanics what stood
out the most about thompson was his
composure
this guy was going up against the
biggest names in the world on the
biggest
stage in the world and none of it phased
him
i mean i've played dota for 12 years now
and
i don't know i've been started playing
like more serious one year ago and
yeah no i'm a ti feels good we were
counseling it of course
yeah i mean not our confidence for sure
but
we are good skilled team and we're going
to beat
every team here ti8 wasn't just
thompson's first ti
it was his first noteworthy land
thompson
three thousand dollars in your pocket
you come to tr you get an email from
notel you're a ti champion
what that's
not to say he never felt the pressure
still looking good he's zumel on his
second life goes balling in
catches out the oracle as well as
thompson's arc one on the backlights
here's thompson
he's just gonna trying to tp his hero
out of there but he must be he tp to the
tier one
what's he thinking he's being pinked
here crit gonna give him the tip or that
he didn't get dumpstered from time to
time i don't know which one he wants
thompson oh he went in invis and then he
came out of it
they had him under the tower they dive
in and find the kill
he said it all there with the whoops but
he never succumbed to that pressure
he always bounced back i want to be
clear that i think no one else in the
world would win that game on monkey king
when you're that far behind there's no
denying the absurdity
of thompson's feat in just a few days he
achieved what takes most players
years i would not have picked them as a
favorite for a single series they played
at ti
no and somehow they did it he went from
an unproven amateur
to a dota god not to mention one of the
highest earning players in dota history
he even got invited to dinner at
finland's presidential palace
now the question on a lot of people's
minds is can he ever achieve that kind
of success again
and the answer is it doesn't really
matter through a combination of
fate luck and sheer unadulterated
resilience
thompson's name is carved into the aegis
forever and in the world of dota
that means you've ascended that you've
become immortal
that come what may you will forever be
one of the best the greatest cinderella
story
in the history of dota 2. immortality
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages